>> You know, one of the things we, both of us have
talked about for a long time is the importance of a conceptual model.
>> True.
>> And, the fact that, you know, the designer has some model of
what this thing is, and the person using it is trying to figure out
what the model is, and the only thing to go on is the device itself. And,
you said, you had trouble with this. And it looks to me
like it's a pretty straightforward bowl, so what's the story?
>> Well I, I came across this at a hotel in, in Stockholm, Sweden. They
had a whole big stack of them jumbled up for us to put our breakfast cereal
in. And so, I made the mistake of putting my breakfast cereal in it. I happen to
have some cereal here. [SOUND] I poured the the cereal into the bowl, and
then I added some milk. And I do like my milk, so.
>> All the way up to the rim.
>> Yeah, because that's just the way I like it
and then I put it down on the table. [NOISE]
>> [LAUGH].
>> Because the base of the bowl is at an angle to where the bowl is.
>> Now that does not require an, a warning notice. That requires a redesign.
>> So the conceptual model of a bowl is that it's flat.
>> Yes.
>> And horizontal. And you.
>> [CROSSTALK] And that's what people expect.
>> And as long as you're holding it this way, it looks like it is, right?
>> Yes, and particularly the way it was jumbled one bowl on top of the other.
>> Right, so, and actually.
>> [CROSSTALK] And there was nothing that let you know.
>> You were, you were holding it in your hand when you
filled it. If you had filled it while it was on the table,
>> Right.
>> Then it would have been okay.
>> Yes.
>> Except, you maybe couldn't have put as milk in as you want.
>> Yeah, but this is a breakfast buffet, so you're standing there with the
bowl in your hand. Now what was it, it was intended for was to
make a nice presentation for having the chef fill this bowl and then a
waiter bring it out to your table. So they pressed it into a different service.